abone ol
bu
[Müzik]
Merhaba Denizli nasılsınız
Hayatımdan hiç hayal kırıklığına
uğramadım daha
şimdi
hayatında hiç hayal kırıklığına uğramış
bir adamın hikayesini anlatacağım size
şey yav Nasıl hayal kırıklığına
uğramadın yani Hiçbir hayalin olmadı
Efendim yol boyunca hep başarılarla bu
geçti ömrün Ondan sonra hiç mi moralim
bozulmadı Hiç mi engelle karşılaşmadığı
falan bir Tabi öyle değil
hayatımda da
Ben hayatımda hiç hayal kırıklığına
uğramadım Çünkü hiç hayal görmedim
da hayal kurdum
bu Hayal görmekle Hayal kurmak arasında
bir fark var Müsaadenizle ben bu akşam
biraz onu anlatmak istiyorum şimdi Hayal
dediğiniz mekanizma şu an noktasında sın
kendini be noktasında görmek istiyorsun
Hayal gördüğün zaman hop Astra bir
seyahatle kendi Nobel noktası da
görüyorsun ama hayal kurduğun zaman a
noktasından B noktasına ha zihninde bir
yolculuk yapıyorsun o yolculuğun bütün
merhaleleri geçiyorsun zihninde
ve o yolculuk senin hedeflerin varsa bu
yolculukta Ama senin kontrol
edebileceğin ve edemeyeceğim bir sürü
şartta var
hayatın doğal akışı içinde
bu dramalar var felaketler var
İrrasyonel Engeller Var doğru mu Bütün
bunların şans var Bütün bunların bir
algoritması var yani Hayal Hayal
görmekle Hayal kurmak arasındaki fark
bir Algoritma farkın öyle bedavadan
Hayal gördüğü zaman Bu bir Algoritma ile
düşünüyorsun Ama hayal kurduğu zaman bir
haritalama yapıyorsun Bir Algoritma
oluşturuyor Sun ben bunu çok önemsiyorum
işte
Bu sadece hayal kurduğun zaman işte bir
iki o balon gibi patlaya patlaya biliyor
hayaller Ama bunu haritayı o algoritmayı
oluşturduğu zaman genellikle olumlu
neticeler alabiliyorsun şimdi ay
hayatımda Ben bir sürü bir şeyler yaptım
irili ufaklı ın başarılarında olduğu
vesaire ama bana şey daha ilginç geliyor
ya bir sürü değişim başarısızlıkla
sonuçlandı hayatın doğal akışı bu
yaptığımız işlerin içinde en azından
benim hayatımda öyle cereyan etti bir
sürü başarısızlık oldu bu
başarısızlıklarına geri dönüp baktığım
zaman
kendimce bazı dersler çıkardı bu
dersleri de o
kurulmakta olduğum hayat boyunca devam
eden algoritmanın içine kendimce ile
yerleştirmeye çalıştım Sen bugün işte
benim
başarısızlıklarından şey olmuş Neşet
etmiş doğmuş bu
algoritmanın bazı parçalarını sizle
paylaşmak istiyorum ama önce bu çok
güzel bir
konuşmaya şahit olduk Bir yarıda sevgili
akademisyen dostumuz laodike anlattı mı
harika laodike harika Aziz pavlus
laodike anılara bayağı bir fırça atar
yedi kiliseden biridir biliyorsunuz
laodike Yaaa seminerdeki 7 önemli
kiliseden biridir ilk kiliselerden Aziz
pavlus bir fırça atar Şimdi burada with
IKEA çok
ileri gitmiş bir kent refah var şey var
yani zenginlik var zaten gördüğünüz şey
şehrin ve kadar şey bu ne olduğunu da
gördünüz yani iyi planlanmış ve zengin
bir şehir olduğunu gördünüz ve sular
akarmış hali sıcak su var ya sıcak suda
Getiriyorlar mış soğuk suda Getiriyorlar
mış böyle bir zenginlik kentin içindeki
çeşmelerden Aziz pahalı Usta diyor ki ya
diyor siz diyor ne sıcak sınız ve soğuk
sunuz balıksınız Siz diyor
ve omurgasız sınız anlamında söylüyor
bunu
bu sebebi de belli diyor ki aslında
felsefi olarak
ne diyor ki de toplumsal faydaya
dönüşmemiş bir zenginlik zenginlik
değildir refah dediğin şeyin mutlaka
kolektif bir refah olarak anlaşılması
lazım bencil bir zenginlik olarak
anlaşılmaması lazım
laodike a halkı bu öğütleri biraz
dinlemiş Ama bana kalırsa Çok da iyi
Dinleyemem işler ve Yine Bana kalırsa
tarih sahnesinden
rakiplerine göre daha erken bir zamanda
gitmek mecburiyetinde kalmıştı ama o
bilgelik havada asılı kalmış
ama ne yalan söyleyeyim işte o havada
asılı kalan bilgeliği böyle alıp yaşam
enerjisiyle dönüştürme işini de
şimdi aramızda bulunan tanıdığımız gurur
duyduğumuz
denizleri o girişimci ve efendime
söyleyeyim akıllı insanları becermiş
bundan Ben şahsen ve ülkem adına büyük
bir mutluluk duyuyorum ve buna da
yürekten inanıyorum şimdi
Bu bir yaptığım yanlış hayatımda
işlerinde Tabi yani büyük içsel hayatım
zaten yanlışlarla dolu da işlerimde
yaptığım bir yanlış şu oldum bir
tanesinde erken zamanda birtakım sanat
projelerini oluştururken
biz bizeyiz çeşitli olası sonuçlar
karşısında neler yapabileceğimiz
konusunda Hazırlıklı değildik
yani Hani derler ya A planı B planı
falan bir o b plan ve plan o işleri
bilmiyoruz bir tane planımız vardı onu
uygulamaya çalışıyorduk ve onu
uyguladığımız zaman iyi oluyorsa oluyor
Olmazsa da Eyvah Yandık falan diyorduk
ver öyle değilmiş O iş başka bir şey
yapmak lazımmış şimdi şu salon
ışıklarını yakar mısın dostum Şimdi
mesela bir şey yapacağım
o Sizden rica edeceğim Sizler Evet ve
oturduğunuz yerde size 3 şey
söyleyeceğim üçünden birini seçmenizi
istiyorum söylüyorum bunları bu
bu Ajda Pekkan
bu profiterol
bu nairobi
he he he
ya bir dakika bir dakika ya hemen
söyleme
Evet sen Sen sevdiğin Şimdi yan tarafa
geçiyorum Çünkü söylemeniz lazım Ben onu
tahmin edeceğim tamam mı tamam Sana
soruyorum Tamam abi Ayşe'yi Seviyor Ajda
Pekkan profiterol nairobi
Bu bir tanesini seçtim Kafamın içinde
yerleşti yerleştirdim
bu dikkatle bakıyorum sana
bu ve seçtiğini biliyorum Burada bir
zarf var uzattı daha önce koydum buraya
ve
en uzak burada duruyor şimdi dili Lütfen
söyler misin bana Hangisini seçtin
oy ver
da çok ilginç değil mi
bu çalışmıyoruz
ve bu sözcüklerin arasında
Bu bir bağlantı da yok Bak orada ise ben
bunu yapacağız hissetmişim
bu ve ve şöyle bir şey yazmışım buraya
abone ol
bu profiterol
Tamam
o kel bu çok küçük bir sihir oyunu ve
ben bunu
şeylerinde gösteriyorum yani o
tanıtıcı videolarında filan öğretici
videolarında gösteriyor şimdi Adet
yerini bulsun diye bunu becerdim için
küçük bir alkış alacağım ama
ha ama asıl diyeti Tabi sizi
büyük bir sihir oyunu yapmak değildi bir
şey anlatmakta Eğer profiterolü seçmemiş
olsaydın gayrı bir seçmiş olsaydı ben
zaten şöyle bir hazırlık yapmıştı
buradan ayrı bir yazıyordu
bu sabah tek yapmam gereken zarfı böyle
alıp Evet biliyorum nairobi demiştin
demek olacaktı
Ajda Pekkan deseydi ile zarfı
göstermeden
bu çıkartacaktır ve Ajda Pekkan olacak
Evet bunun adın Çok teşekkür ederim
bunun adı bunun adı Ay çoklu sonuçlara
ulaşma şeyi hazırlığı ya da
sihirbazlıkta ki adıyla multiple
outcomes multiple outcomes yani her şeye
olası her sonuca önceden önceden
hazırlanma şey şimdi hayattaki
başarısızlıklarından
aldığım derslerden bir tanesi de şu oldu
oldu biz biz
daha fazla kendi işlerimize odaklanırken
şeyi pek Düşünememiş tik nasıl
söyleyeyim insanları katmayı yani
seyircileri aktif birer örgü olarak
kullanmayı pek bilmiyorduk gençlik
yıllarımızda yani onları sadece bizi
seyreder insanlar olarak görüyorduk
onlara bir şeyler sulu yorduk ve onların
beğenilerini bekliyorduk ama iş öyle
değilmiş iş Öyleymiş
seyircilerin aktif katılımını sağlamak
gerekiyormuş Bu da ne demektir duygusal
Angajman kurmalarını sağlamak
gerekiyormuş bunu bilmiyorduk burada
sonradan öğrendik Mesela işte bu da bir
küçük bir efekt tata tata tata
değişti Çok güzel bence büyük bir
marifet Aferin sihirbazı ama hiç de o
kadar heyecan verici bir şey değil bunun
bu daha heyecan verici bir versiyonu
yapacağız şimdi
Ceylan Hanım'da yardım isteyeceğim sen
Çok
teşekkür ederim Ceren Ceren bize bu
konuda yardımcı olacak ve çok hızlı ve
pratik bir şekilde şöyle bir şey
yapacağım şimdi
teşekkür edeceğim Bu arada geldiğim için
derim Öf bizim
bu yaptığımız var
bu
işte istiyorsan karıştıralım falan filan
O da önemli değil
iki parçaya ayırıyorum bunları şöyle iki
parçaya yazıyorum Tamam Nasıl hızlı şey
yapıyorum soruyorum bu parçayı Mobis
kullanalım bu parçayı Biz kullanalım bu
parçayı ben kullanacağım Tamam Celal
Bunlar Sende Kalsın şimdilik ve bana
göstermeden bana göstermeden
onların İçinden bir tane kağıt seçmeli
istiyorum Tamam bana göstermeden onların
İçinden bir tane kağıt seçmeli istiyorum
seçtin mi
mi Evet seçtim işte lütfen seçtiği
kağıdı herkese göster
o herkes görsün
veya papatya şey arkası çevir Ben o
kağıdı Bana lütfen seçtin kağıdı bu
kağıdı herkes gördü herkes gördü
sen biliyorsun herkes biliyor bir tek
ben bilmiyorum
yok yani hepiniz bile kumpas kurdunuz
bir tanecik iskambil kağıdı ne olduğunu
benden saklıyorsunuz Yani bu mu daha
Evet bana döndürmüş yani de var Koskoca
sihirbazın Ben bunu Bilemeyeceğim yani
Ama Oh oyunumuz bu değil oyunumuz başka
bir şey Şimdi siz bu kağıdı seçtiniz
seçili kağıdı herkes gördü siz
biliyorsunuz Sorum şu
acaba bu kağıt seçilmiş Kağıt olduğunu
biliyor mu bak arada çok büyük bir fark
var siz biliyorsunuz acaba o biliyor mu
genellikle buraya oturur musun o
seçilmiş Kağıt olduğunu biliyormuş Şimdi
Senden ricam şu
lütfen şöyle Tutku desteği sıkı bir
şekilde bir havaya kaldır kolunu şahane
bir anlığına bir anlığına
mı
o zihin güçlerimizi topladığımız
düşünelim ve hatta bunu yapalım
Bu bir anlığına bu seçilen kağıdı
düşünelim
Oh be enerjimizi buraya yönlendirelim o
kağıt size mutluluk veren bir şeyi
temsil etsin
Evet tamam Bu ne yapıyor musunuz
mi Evet Neden olmasın derin nefes al
lütfen
gevşe Bolu'nun yukarı kaldır iyice
kaldır
gevşeğe gevşeğe gevşeğe gevşekçe
rahatlığa rahatlığa rahatlığa rahatla
gevşe
köşe yaşı
bu alkış burada geliyor rap
[Alkış]
bu işi
kolay kısmeti zor kısmı muayene kısmı
bütün kutuya
orada kalan kağıtlara bu kağıtları
hepsine bakıp kontrol edebilirsin
ve dolayısıyla istiyorsan bu kağıtları
da hediye olarak yanında götürebilirsin
Teşekkür ederim ben teşekkür ederim
Umarım beğenmişsinizdir boyu
küçük bir demonstrasyon Ama tahmin
ediyorum bir anlığına bile olsa o Kağıt
yükselirken
Sizin seyirci olarak dahili lies onu
Düşünmeniz Hayal etmeniz oyunun bir
parçası olması Kağıt yükseldiğinde size
bir şeyleri becermiş olmanın bir
şeylerin parçası olmanın mutluluğu
yaşatmıştır diye tahmin ediyorum
İnşallah böyle olmuştur olursa kafanızı
böyle sağlayabilirsiniz herkes böyle
yapsın Herkes böyle yapsın Evet herkes
böyle yapsın
mi
Evet Şu ucuz koltukta oturanlar da Evet
herkes böyle yapsın Şahane bakın
Denizli'ye geldim denizleri ve Seçkin
insanları beni parmağıyla gösteriyor şu
anda bitiş bir duygu bu duygu ikiye
katlamak istiyorum Herkes böyle yapsın
mi Evet çok güzel Şimdi böyle
yapmıştınız ya bunda bir tane daire
çizmeniz istiyorum
o Şahane Dursun buna bir tane üçgen
çizmeniz istiyorum Şahane Bu da dursun
şimdi daire çizerken bunlar
Evet bu da üçgen çizmeniz istiyorum
bu
özellikle Seninki çok iyi altıgen ve
sekizgen aynı anda
o Şahane Burada da şey var Bir daha bak
dolar işareti yapıyor bir de
şey yapıyor öyle işareti yok Evet bir
tanesine daire bir tanesini üçgen
çiziyoruz yapamayanlar yapanları
alkışlıyor Evet
bu da Teşekkür ederim Bu da
başarısızlıklarından edildiği öğrendiğin
derslerden bir tanesi Siz siz olun
beyninizi multitasking denen şeye
zorlamayın bir İki işi aynı anda yapmaya
zorlamayın Eğer buna özellikle çalışmış
bir helikopter pilotu ya da sihirbaz
değilsiniz Ama bu gerçekten önemli çünkü
Focus olmakla ilgili bir şey bu ve
birçok insanda geldi saticilarini
kurarken düşünse stratejilerde kurarken
bu en basit insani şeyi unutuyor Evet
bizim Beynimiz böyle yapılmamış Bu bir
gerçek bunu bu literatürü O yüzden
Karaman'dan okuyabilirsiniz Efendim
vaktim bitiyor ama birkaç dakika müsaade
nizi rica edeceğim şimdi bir şey daha
var
bu kurduğumuz Hayallerde ki risk
faktörünü risk çok önemli bir şeydir
risk sıradan bir başarısızlığı tanımı
değildir riskin riske hem ihtimal
gerçekleşme ihtimali düşük olacak hem de
ucunda Bedel olacak bak işin ucunda
Bedel varsa ve ihtimal düşükse ona
risklidir Şimdi mesela tabancaya bir
tane Kurşun otu pırt yapıyorsun çıplak
nedir bunun adı
bu ne Rus ruleti Evet beş tane
koyuyorsun pırt yapıyorsun çıplak bunun
adı nedir Bir Laz ruleti Evet şimdi
birincisi de risk denir ikincisine riski
denmez risk sözcüğü bro karşılamaz daha
büyük bir sözcük bulmak lazım onu ben
Türkçeye e hediye ediyorum riks riks
denir ona
tanrisidir Öyleymiş şimdi ben de
hayatımızdaki riskleri ve riskleri ve
değerlendirmeyi ases etmek derler ya şey
yapmayı ölçüp tartmaya bize hatırlatsın
diye son derece riskli son derece
tehlikeli son derece sinir bozucu
bu ve anca büyük bir cesaret sahibi
insanların yapabileceği çok zor bir şey
yapacağız huzurlarınızda
ne ile yapacağım
o o
Evet şu anda bu söylediğinden etkilenmiş
Bu salonda bir sen varsa bir ben varım
yok
ama olsun Ben yine de yapacağım Fakat
önce bu Yapacağım işte kullanacağım
iyileri gerçek iğneler olduğunu kontrol
etmek üzere Ceren'i bir kez daha sahneye
davet ediyorum
Ceren Çok teşekkür ederim kızları yorum
seni şöyle şuraya alacağım ve Bu
iğneleri al kontrol et bir kadar nazik
bir insan Yani ben olsam kendi elime
değil değil buradaki sihirbazın elinde
falan batırdım şahane bir insansın Evet
senden ricam şu Bu iğneleri teker teker
bana yutturmaya istiyorum
mi Evet teker teker dikkatli
bi evet
mi Evet işte onu diyorum briks Evet Evet
Evet eminim
bu
heyecanlandır Ama asıl değil mi canlı
almam lazım
39 lütfen dokun
bu ve Narince içeri gönder onları Evet
söyle iterek Ne arayacağım
abone ol
hu hu
o çocuğa Gel istersen
abone ol
Ama tabii tabii devam edebilirsin elini
korkak alıştırma ağabey Evet kalan
iğnelerine lütfen deme Evet tabii tabii
tabii
tabii canım ne olacak
Yok ya bir şey olmaz sihirbaz dediğin o
kadar da pahalı bir şey değil devam
bu hepsini hepsini be
o o
abone ol
var mı
Bak şimdi şöyle rica edeceğim
o lütfen eve
abone ol
sen
yanımda olduktan ve Narince içeriği
abone ol
bu
ev
Lütfen yanıma gelir misin
Yok yok yok
herkes evinde otursun teker teker bütün
sıraları dolaşarak
herkese maliyet gireceğim Evet bu Winx
ile ilgili müzikle ilgili bir şeydir
Şimdi işi biraz daha zorlaştırmak
istiyorum ve masaüstünde bir makara
ipliği var onu alır mısın lütfen Ben ve
aşağı yukarı
37.4 santimlik bir parça
O biraz daha uzun Evet biraz daha Eh
Evet bir çay koparırım Salonu
bu şahanesi şimdi dikkatli bakışların
altında şunu yapacağım
çok
dikkatli bakışları altında şunu
yapacağım
en son olarak o suyu rica edeceğim
senden
o o
Çok
teşekkür ederim
Çok teşekkür ederim Evet
evet
Denizli'de olmak çok büyük bir mutluluk
sizlerle birlikte olmak çok büyük
mutluluk biraz vaktimi açtım Ama
birlikte olup fikirlerimizi
paylaşabileceğimiz için ve kendimi çok
mutlu hissediyorum görüşmek üzere
Evet efendim
ki benim iğnem ne olacak Yine beni
kadardı yine benim karar verdim yani
Ama siz bir şey söyleyeceğim bak
samimiyetten söylüyorum siz bir vallahi
billahi ya hadi iğneleri yuttuk ya
ipliği de yuttuk su işleyeceğiz Bunlar
da diyor ki bunlar benefıt buradan
çıksın
Yok yok artık yani O kadar da değil Onu
yapana
bu dünya üzerinde 30 binden fazla üyesi
olan uluslararası sihirbazlar Derneği
internet sonucu için Society
dünyanın en iyi Kamer'e iyi sihirbazı
bu tanımıyla Merlin ödülü veriyor kolay
bir şey değil oraya yapmak
var
ama Ben Türk olduğum için gazla
çalışıyorum ve elimden geleni yapacağıma
söz veriyorum elimden geleni yapacağım
derken Ellerim boş mu ya boş boş duymak
istiyorum boş
çok güzel
bu boş
abone ol
Çok
teşekkür ederim Çok teşekkür ederim son
olarak lütfen bunları gerçek iğneler
olduğunu kontrol edelim gerçek iğneler
olduğunu kontrol edelim gerçek ve çok
seyahat etmiş hileler buradan alırlar
Beyler alkışlarıyla Çok teşekkür
ediyorum sakın
sessiz olun böyle birşey evde yapmaya
kalkışmayın Ama illa yapacağım
diyorsanız Biz şöyle bir de aklınızdan
çıkarmayın girer yine sayısıyla çıkan
ile sayısı birbirini tutsun Sizi
seviyorum Görüşmek üzere sağlık